tutti ragazzi e benvenuti che sono video
sono fa dj ed oggi siamo sul gozzo
layton ragazzi volevo dirvi che allora
praticamente prima edilizia o ucciso una
capra qua devo dirvi ragazzi che sarebbe
fare una patch digos simulator che
uscirà nel prossimo episodio e quindi
ragazzi questo episodio lo devo farvi
vedere le cose che è primatista lampo
ancora non avete visto che è che io
conosco perché ormai ho giocato a troppe
volte a parte il fatto che ho trovato
una capra e non staccherò la mia lingua
dal suo collo sosta ragazzi aiuto ma
quella è la e la mia lingua o la sua
ragazzi è rimasta incastrata pace
all'anima sua
volevo farvi dei ragazzi nelle cose che
non mi ancora fatto vedere lista mappa
che sono solo un casino ma almeno così
la prossima volta ecco infatti se
entriamo qua dentro c'è allora io io non
bull non so perché ma ditemi se è
normale
ritiratevi stronzi al mio cospetto re
capra ragazzi è vero che questi sono i
devoti di fa vj tu non mi piace fai
schifo
e voi volevo dirvi che con questa zona
qui si trova in una torre di questo
spessore come cazzo è possibile miei
soldi io vi prometto farla soldi e belle
donne dal re che sono una cosa avrebbe
le donne ovviamente femmine di capra per
chi lo chiedesse ragazzi aspettatevi la
cosa più assurda che potreste mai vedere
pronti io evoco capre dal cielo
non so se è normale questo lurido
stronzo
come la mettiamo adesso è lu ritmo
qualche mila di merda ciò ne ho invocato
e 14mo donna è successo sta andando la
cos'è ragazzi aiuto ok l'ho preso
almeno quello ragazzi è successo di
tutto non ho neanche capito perché sono
attaccato a una capra perché i ragazzi
oggi leggo capre a caso comunque ragazzi
volevo capire se alla togliti dai
[ __ ]
io non capisco perché oggi la gente le
capre devono rimanere incastrate nei
muri e comunque ragazzi sta a casa se
riesco ad entrarci c'è una porca [ __ ]
pure un secchio ci sei metri vi testo
cosa qui blu se glielo prefetto ragazzi
vi farò vedere una cosa che di senso ne
ha sicuramente poco tanto per cambiare
il tuo gioco
niente se io lecco sta roba e poi vado a
recare questa roba qui che non capito
bene neanche che cazzo è perfetto se
guardo in alto dovrebbe eccoci siamo
cioè un cazzo di ufo gaze mi stanno
portando su saturno è una che sarà un
viaggio epico cazzo ci siamo ecco perché
sei camera mia quando nella riordino
diciamo grazie a quello [ __ ]
maledetto spazio non c'è che la vita non
riesco a camminare è una merda chiesto
tizia un astronauta perché c'è un
astronauta la pensiamo nello spazio mi
sembra giusto buongiorno zio ma qual
buon vento la porta da queste parti riva
i giardini ciechi vano sa in piscina noi
andiamo a vediamo qui perché è
divertente ma vero amico mio stato è
stato un piacere io però devo andare mi
dispiace buon lavoro e cc si vede ok
però se qualcuno non mi dà un passaggio
la vedo un po difficile taxi volevo
provare ragazzi senza però se funziona
mega jump che sarebbe un'altra mappa che
cos'è ci posso entrare no ragazzi e
cazzo in senso ha
perfetto ragazzi so che sono una star ma
al tappeto rosso così lungo poteva
evitarlo ragazzi sto per cimentarmi in
un salto emozionante ma prima di farlo
voglio testare se è sicuro quindi vai tu
[ __ ] sembra che si stia divertendo
quindi posso andarci tranquillamente
perché sta tornando indietro con che
cazzo di criterio fisico chi vi ha dato
il permesso di tornare indietro lurido
stronzo vieni quei ragazzi tanto lui si
dilaterà solo proviamo noi che siamo dei
professionisti vediamo se riesco a fare
qualcosa di decente pronti a gara 3 2 1
[ __ ] perfetto noto ai togliti dai
e allora sei stronzo forte ti ho detto
di toglierti dal cazzo 321 del collo
false sco che il cas nov abbiamo fatto
un punteggio di merda
ho beccato posso riuscire
alberi delle palle perché chi via
mestoli quanto cazzo ha fatto due 200 in
si va beh ma [ __ ] potevo fare un
punteggio migliore ragazze si devo
ritrovare così quella roba laggiù ci
regala così stero nuova vena figata
prega polistena figata pazzesca minchia
fantastico regalo sempre desiderato fare
lo skater professionista che cazzo
succede
porca [ __ ] ragazzi me casa miike
lasciato il gioco perfetto sono
soddisfazioni eccoci qua ragazzi sono
uscito scelta è stato un traguardo
riuscirà a bloccare gozzi muletto non ci
sono mai riuscito tanto posso entrarci
nel cannone cioè lo so magari riesco a
centrare quella cazzo di scatola
perfetto ok ragazzi si abbattuto il mio
[ __ ] ecco non pensavo funzionasse
effettivamente non non ci speravo sì ma
io sono più prodi questo vado senza
cannone perfetto è una che bella così
ragazzi questo questa è la rincorsa
giusta cioè dovrei fare un casino tipo
non perché ho beccato malissimo una
rampa perfetta ho fatto meno a caso a
caso
tutta la bonino a como e che ad un
trampolino a caso ho fatto quanto fatto
cinquantamila porca [ __ ]
io non ho capito da dove spuntato nel
trampolino mi ami e mi è spuntato così a
caso ci arriviamo è più efficiente
nell'ascensore 100 metri quadri
trafugati marchi a [ __ ] per quanto lega
pro non fatemi provare l'ultimo perché
eccolo lì ecco questa è la rincorsa che
ti fa capire che sei un pro è una cosa
mai
vai vai vai vai vai vai ma eccolo lì
ecco se devo beccare l'altro trampolino
sì ma che cazzo di mira ciò che cazzo di
mira ciò si si si
dio mio quanto fatto frey che in crazy
jump perché non soltanto che non cresci
lega perché sennò succede un disastro
nei primati la togli la zac togli la
zampa ma sei stupido chi fai male
deficiente fa il cazzo che vuoi io te
l'ho detto poi fai decidi pubblico
ragazzi e mi è venuta un'idea assurda
che non so che cazzo possa uscire ma ci
provo io ci provo ma non prometto niente
ios tantissimo che cazzo di senso ha
tutto questo perché non ce lo fa come
cazzo centrato un trampolino con una
balena ma [ __ ] non si fa sotto
donna che cazzo se riuscite
sì sì sì ce l'ho fatta ce lo fa no no no
no no no troppo diveniva e di là e di là
dove cazzo fai ragazzo che sto andando
ma dio mio non hai capito un asse di
trampolino e dalla dall'altra parte
dall'altra parte ma è una cosa che non
non avrà non ha senso non ha un cazzo di
perché sto volando con una balena allo
ragazzi un attimo che siano in prova
ecco perfetto miari mi ha disputato
eccoci qui era era ora se mi chiama ci
voleva tanto a prendere uno scivolo
decentemente ragazzi balena sugli
scivoli non lo vedrete mai più nella
vita penso credo neanche io forse vero
soprattutto anzi spero di non essere
sotto quando cade più che altro ho fatto
un milione
ho fatto un milione malizia con la
balena pazzesco ed ora
preparatevi alla cosa più terrificante
mai visto
che cosa cazzo sono un bambino enorme
con degli occhi bruttissimi che chi che
va in giro sculettano a perfect ragazzi
è il bambino di godzilla lucera fatemi
capire senza fa ed ecco dio è la cosa
più inquietante che abbia mai visto
ragazzi sono un bambino ma che cosa fa
eccolo è bene così benissimo magari se
ci passò sotto ma che ai cuccioli non
mai male al pancino e ma io non dormo
stanotte non so se fa più paura questo o
outlast tra i due tra i due se la
contendono io ve lo dico poi provare se
riesco a pensare che il cazzo di
deltaplano che sarebbe una cosa
fenomenale ma devo riuscire a beccarlo
cosa impossibile
tutti i togliti dai [ __ ] brown ciao
ragazzi ci siamo ci siamo se sì l'ho
preso tutto per l'ho preso
sì ma no vai su vice un cazzo mica
beccato janò madonna ragazzi ho beccato
250 alberi non fosse normale mi sa che
ti sei fatto un po male ma facciamo
finta di niente perché prova a centrare
il buco anche se non penso di riuscirci
ma cifra merda l'ho mancato di brutto va
bene non importa è stata è stato in gran
volo voglio solo vedere che cazzo
succede se faccio così perché ormai ho
visto di tutto già non mi stupirebbe di
niente ma voglio vedere che cosa cazzo i
suoi fuori regalati o paure ve lo dico
io sono diventato nero c'è ma per chi ha
gli occhi storti non aveva gli occhi
dovrebbero essere davanti non quei
ragazzini che possono chiudere qui il
video dopo tutto il suo casinò e niente
ragazzi come solito sei lì non è
piaciuto lo stato un momento mi piace
anche a facili facebook con i video
fatte nella descrizione sono state fra i
siti iscrivetevi e te pareva
noi ci rivediamo in un prossimo video
bene ragazzi
io non so che cosa cazzo sono questi ma
sono veramente figli quella a tutti
ragazzi e benvenuti a questo